Abdelatif kesich vous voyez avec un
grand sourire en entendant vos acteurs
amateurs ça vous touche ce qu'ils disent
là oui complètement c'est c'est c'est on
a l'impression que que justement ça ça
donne un sens à tout ce qu'on a fait de
voir le bonheur que ce que ça procure à
à à cette population à ces gens qui nous
ont beaucoup aidé d'ailleurs à cette il
y a eu vraiment une très belle énergie
dans cette ville qui qui a qui on qui
ont vraiment participé à à ce film et
puis
et et puis c'est vrai que ils ne sont
pas ils sont pas désabusé il y a il y a
une vraie
volonté d'ailleurs principale aussi on
va voir ça avec elle tout de suite mais
juste une question pourquoi avoir
choisis des amateurs justement moi je je
ne choisis pas nécessairement que des
amateurs j'aime j'aime mélanger mélanger
j'aime qu'il y ait sur sur un plateau de
cinéma j'aime qu'il y ait des gens qui
soient des des des professionnels il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs qui sont
professionnels sur sur mon plateau qui
apportent leur leur méthodes de de
travail leur professionnalisme et puis
il y a ces gens qui ont qui ont un
véritable talent un véritable donc que
que qui qui n'ont pas d'expérience mais
qui apportent cette cette cette énergie
cette fraîcheur et et de mélanger les
deux ça j'ai l'impression que ça ça ça
dynamise un un plateau de de cinéma et
on est on est toujours en danger les uns
par rapport aux autres dans dans dans
dans une dans une très bonne énergie et
c'est et ça apporte beaucoup ça apporte
beaucoup d'émotions sur un plateau de
mélanger les deux affier dit justement
amatrice vous vous l'étiez avant ce film
meilleur espoir féminin vous vous
attendiez à à ce titre j'en rêvais parce
que vous n'aviez jamais fait de scène
avant hein ah pas du tout non rien du
tout même pas un cours de théâtre
pourquoi même pas un cours c'était vous
disiez j'ai j'ai lu quelque part que
c'était trop cher c'est ça non mais
enfin
j'ai mes parents avaient pas les moyens
de me payer des cours en plus des études
et tout donc mais je m'entraîis à la
maison par vous vous viviez dans les
quartiers nord de Marseille quartier un
petit peu difficile qu'est-ce qui pousse
une jeune fille des quartier Nord qui
n'a jamais fait de théâtre à venir au
castingab d'Abdelatif comment comment
est-ce qu'on fait cette démarche là moi
j'ai toujours voulu être actrice ça
vraiment un rêve de de petite fille et
euh et voilà j'ai j'ai j'ai j'avais la
chance de pouvoir passer un casting donc
je me suis présenté et c'est le dessin
et alors hier soir cette petite
statuette entre vos mains ça ça générer
j'imagine beaucoup d'émotions oui
énormément h vous le dédiez à qui à mes
parents à vos parents vous imaginez
qu'au-delà de cette récompense de votre
jeu d'actrice hein qui est merveilleux
dans ce film il y a peut-être aussi un
symbole derrière qui est qui est qui est
que on peut pe réussir justement en
venant des quartiers nords et puis il y
a aussi cette idée de la des des
nouvelles générations issu de
l'immigration français mais issu des
nouvelles génération vous vous comprenez
cette valeur symbolique possible de ce
prix pour vous vous l'acceptez ça vous
parle pas ou si si tout à fait oui et
qu'est-ce que vous voulez en faire alors
bah je vais continuer de rêver
j'espère j'espère
continuer je crois je crois que c'est
bien aussi qu'il y ait qu'il y ait qu'il
y ait dans dans dans le cinéma français
cette diversité et que
oui un nouau souffle au
cinéma quelqu'un qui qui a qui a un
véritable don de de de comédienne pour
moi c'est c'est c'est une actrice née
elle elle a apporté une énergie sur sur
le plateau extraordinaire et et je crois
que que que c'est que c'est que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
d'exceptionnel pour le cinéma que de que
de justement que des gens qui viennent
qui viennent d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas
spécialement des des des des enfants de
la balle puissent puissent apporter
apporter leur
le cette cette ce sens du vrai aussi qu'
il il y a beaucoup de de symboles dans
votre film et puis rien que dans le
titre La graine et le mulet alors c'est
la graine de couscous le mulet c'est le
poisson mais il y a quand même
énormément de symboles derrière tout ça
on a l'impression que tout est dit avec
peu de mots finalement oui la graine
c'est c'est c'est ce qui gène c'est ce
qui est en devenir c'est c'est cette
cette volonté aussi de diffuser cette
énergie ce ce ce de de de faire que que
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse tous
s'exprimer aussi hein comment comment
comment vous expliquez ce ce succès là
il y a déjà quand même 650000 à peu près
téléspectateurs enfin spectateurs pardon
des formations professionnelles qui sont
allés voir votre film comment vous
expliquez ce succès alors qu'il y a pas
d'effets spéciaux il y a pas la grosse
affiche il y a pas la grosse artillerie
qu'est-ce que selon vous les gens
viennent chercher dans votre cinéma
parce que vous aviez déjà eu quatre
récompenses he pour votre précédent film
donc c'est vouses pas votre premier coup
d'essai quand même oui mais je crois que
les gens sont sensible au fait qu'on
représente justement ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une microociété mais qui en fait
euh ce sont des gens qu'on qu'on
rencontre tous les jours dans dans et
qui et qui sont qui sont justement très
peu représenté dans dans dans le cinéma
une population qui est très peu
représentée dans le cinéma et les gens
se reconnaissent complètement et
adhèrent à cette à cette représentation
le monsieur dans le film qui veut monter
un restaurant pour aider ses enfants
c'est un peu votre père ou pas du tout
parce que il y a une histoire qui est un
petit peu le personnage est inspiré de
mon père et inspiré de toute cette
génération d'hommes qui qui sont qui ont
qui ont beaucoup travaillé qui ont qui
ont qui sont qui se sont beaucoup
sacrifiés qui travaent sur le chantier
sur pour pour pour leur pour leurs
enfants pour que leurs enfants a une vie
plus joyeuse hein en tout cas c'était
c'était ils ont été souvent dans une
dans une grande abnégation d'eux- même
hein qu'ils ont beaucoup donné et et et
euh en tout cas moi j'avais envie de de
de leur rendre hommage j'avais envie de
de de leur dire aussi l'affection que
que qu'on leur portait C notre nouvelle
génération c'est ces nouvelles
génération la mienne celle d'afia et
puis celle qui qui qui arrive leur leur
dire not notre not ou Simp oui et puis à
qui ils ont transmis des valeurs aussi
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir accepté de
de venir nous livrer ce témoignage après
cette belle récompense merci nous sommes
ravis en tout cas nous d'avoir participé
à France 2 la production de ce film et
pour information sachez que les films
financés par votre service public de la
télévision France 2 et France 3 confondu
ont récolté hier soir en tout pas moins
de 10 césards voilà c'est dit